is there something you could say to what
it takes to hire a great team what uh
what's a good interview process how do
you know uh the guy or Gallery are gonna
make a great member of uh of a
engineering team that's doing some of
the hardest work in the world
you know we developed an interview
process that I was quite fond of it's a
little bit of a hard interview process
because the best interviews you ask
somebody about what they're interested
in and what they're good at
and if if they can describe to you
something that they worked on and you
saw they really did the work they solved
the problems
and you saw their passion for it
um and you could ask but but what makes
that hard is you have to ask a probing
question about it you have to be smart
enough about what they're telling you
their expert at to ask a good question
and so it takes a pretty talented team
to do that
but if you can do that that's how you
tap into ah this person cares about
their work they really did the work
they're excited about it that's the kind
of person I want at my company
you know at Google they taught us about
their interview process
and it was a little bit different
um
you know
we we evolved the process at Boston
Dynamics where it didn't matter if you
were an engineer or you were an uh
administrative assistant or a financial
person or a technician
you gave us a presentation you came in
and you gave us a presentation you had
to stand up and talk in front of us
and I just thought that was great to tap
into those things I even subscribed to
you at Google they taught us and I think
I understand why you're right they're
hiring tens of thousands of people they
need a more standardized process so they
would sort of err on the other side
where they would ask you a standard
question I'm going to ask you a
programming question and I'm just going
to ask you to you know write code in
front of me
that's a terrifying you know application
process yeah it does let you compare
candidates really well but it doesn't
necessarily let you tap in to who they
are right because you're asking them to
answer your question instead of you
asking them about what they're
interested in
um but frankly that process is hard to
scale and even at Boston Dynamics
we're not doing that with everybody
anymore we're but we are still doing
that with you know the technical people
um but we've because we too now need to
sort of increase our rate of hiring uh
not everybody's giving a presentation
anymore but you're still ultimately
trying to find that uh basic seed of
passion yeah into the world you know did
they really do it did they did they find
something interesting or curious you
know
um and do they care about it I think uh
somebody admires
um Jim Keller and he
he likes details
so one of the ways you could if you get
a person to talk about what they're
interested in how many details like how
much of the Whiteboard can you fill out
yeah well I think you figure out did
they really do the work if they know
some of the details yes and if they have
to wash over the details well then they
didn't do it the Special engineering the
work is in the details yeah